i'm stephanie wong from the google
campus in sunnyvale and we're talking
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
baseball
[Applause]
today we're trying to figure out what
makes players popular with fans in major
league baseball
and how you can use machine learning to
predict it and joining me
mj jacob cloud engineer from new york
city
and dale markowitz applied ai engineer
here at google hey guys hey steph okay
so first of all
are you both baseball fans at all i'm a
baseball fan
but i'm really a data nerd so i think
being a
nerd makes you kind of be a baseball fan
because there's just so much to analyze
it's like being in a candy store what
about you mj uh yeah i would say i have
a pretty healthy relationship with
baseball for tea reasons number one when
i was a kid
growing up i used to play home run derby
all the time and nothing's like just
knocking some pitches out of the park
uh and number two i love going to
in-person baseball games like
being able to eat a hot dog with your
drink with your friends with your
sunglasses on it's a beautiful show
so let's get to our lineup we have some
amazing guests today
we have josh frost vice president of
product at major league baseball
and you kevin youkilis a three-time
mlb all-star a player who was incredibly
popular for reasons that weren't obvious
unless you were a data nerd
all right so you guys what do you think
are the types of data sets that would
help determine
a really popular player online number
one i'd love to collect data from tick
tock
lots of trends coming out of tick tock
of course number two
the most popular songs that are
currently trending and then number three
the most popular dances and the reason
for this is think about back in the day
when john wall was trending right
everyone was like do the john wall do
the john
wall
it was crazy because while he was an
awesome basketball player
i think a lot more people knew him and
he was a lot more popular
because of that dance in that song that
came out dale what about you can you
fill the rest of the world
on social media with tick tock stuff
that you want too
but i also want some more boring things
like
maybe how is popularity measured and
like what sort of users are more likely
to
submit answers like what is their ages
what device types so all of the unsexy
stuff that
actually can make a big difference in
the end what do you think stephanie
yeah i think there are a couple in
between things
for fun and boring i guess it's
tick-tock dances because obviously those
are a big driver for what's trending
these days
or does a player have a orange or red
beard like justin turner
so there are a ton of things that you
can look at and even social justice
issues
like if they've been really active about
those things in the past
yeah and i think that's super important
that last point you just touched on
stuff because at the end of the day
i love when players can use their
platform to make a difference in the
world
and when they become popular because of
that i think that's an incredible
two birds one stone hard to fit that
into a column
but it'd be neat joining us now is josh
frost with a little bit more about how
to define
an all-star baseball player and to talk
about an exciting challenge for data
scientists who
love the game hey how's it going okay so
josh we know that there is an exciting
new
kaggle competition and mlb can you tell
us a little bit more about the details
of it
yeah it's a really exciting one because
it's uh pretty different we feel from
what's been done before in the kaggle
space and certainly in our world
effectively we're trying to ask uh ai
and ml enthusiasts to try and predict uh
what makes
a popular player so digital engagement
is really how we measure that
and we're giving pretty rich data sets
to challenge people to say
can you define some signal can you
create an algorithm
to help predict player popularity and we
have
really rich data sets there lots of
documentation on kind of you know what
the
information is but ultimately we think
it's a really unique opportunity for you
to
you know try your skill sets at making a
prediction at a business problem that we
think about every day
and that lots of sports and media
companies
alike are thinking about every day as
[Music]
well
wow all right so josh i gotta know
what makes an all-star player in your
opinions so i think the question that's
really interesting is
what makes someone beloved by the fans
right not just for
you know the what you do on the field
that's very creative but
staying after the sign autograph
creating a cool video
collabing with local artists all those
things are really strong signals that
help define the modern all-stars
so josh talking about players that he
beloved i got to tell you so i'm an
applied ai engineer here at google
and i'm sort of like a big fan girl
actually for what you do
and what the mlb does with data i mean
we're going to enter into this kaggle
competition like what sort of data are
we going to have to work with
yeah we think it's really unique because
it's you know not just an
entertainment product it's a performance
product as well it's really a business
of course you're getting these really
unique data sets combining the
differences between
on-field performance kind of the
business metrics of you know how fans
interact in the digital space uh both on
our
core platforms and even on social as
well so you'll get some pretty
distinct data sets there and then you
know what we
call our stats api says this huge range
of information
uh that allows you to marry it up with
something that you really wouldn't think
about so
you know something that we've found a
lot of interest in looking at already is
when you see spikes for someone on
either their player page views or
on their social files like did that
correlate with anything that happened on
the field
is there anything that you've learned
using all this now combined data that
was very surprising that you didn't
expect
yeah i think you know i'm always
surprised and impressed how
uh nationality and kind of like country
of origin
can be a really strong influence so when
shohei ohtani plays there's going to be
strong correlations um you know really
throughout asia
but there are also other kind of like
less well-known correlations on
you know when this player comes and
plays at the stadium
he over indexes why maybe he's from that
town maybe he's from that
uh from that area or played college ball
there
so being from san francisco myself i
totally agree that
an origin is a huge uh part of the whole
equation for me but
who would you vote for in this case well
i'm super biased i'm from chicago
or outside of chicago so i'm always
going to vote for the cubs
but this year i think i have a pretty
good case uh you know
recently javi baez has this incredible
play he's called el mago which means the
magician in spanish and
he can literally create something out of
nothing and he is a top performer so
i'll definitely be voting for him but
he's also a top performer because
he is so dynamic and you know having
swag
kind of impossible to define but also
definitely noticeable as well
or could popularity be based off the
shoes or the bling that they're wearing
we were joking that i would love to
create a metric for the swag
chain that fernando tati's junior wears
that like every time he makes this
mind-blowing grand slam um you know
he's putting this very cool uh kind of
hilarious big gold chain on like
no data can measure that but like plenty
of data could measure
how people react and feel about it right
as we learn about the more subtle things
that make
players really valuable are are fans
understanding that are they are they
understanding when a player is valuable
even if it's not in a
swag way yeah that's what i love about
kind of this era of baseball
is that there's never been a deeper
appreciation from a fan
or a front office perspective for uh on
field performance right so
it's really fun and exciting to talk
about kind of you know swag and all
those other topics
yeah i've always believed that all
players have a data story mostly because
uh that helps track the way that they've
evolved from someone who was playing
little league
all the way to being a major leaguer
right and the data story
uh can be you know in how a scout
discovered them
it could be an anomaly or a pattern uh
kevin euclis is a famous example
uh commonly referred to as the greek god
of walks where uh
he was noticed uh because he was
excellent getting on base
uh through walks fall four
something else that you've seen in the
last couple seasons
is that we're using not just data but
video as well
we have consumer data on field data we
have
business data and industry data now
machine learning and ai is giving us
these opportunities to
start uh gleaning insights uh across
all of these different data sets
thank you so much for joining today and
we hope that we get to see you on the
field out there someday
yeah can't wait do you think you can
have an impact on america's pastime
maybe you can join the mlb player
digital engagement forecasting
competition
the competition will dive deeper into
the player fandom of america's pastime
the result the ability to predict the
most popular players for mlb
and yo you can win fifty thousand
dollars in prize money
so josh mentioned three-time mlb
all-star player
kevin euclis and we just happen to have
kevin eucles here on the show with us
today
kevin
let's get it good morning
good morning thank you so much for being
here i have to ask first off
what is it like being known as the greek
god of
walks and do you think that's why you
were so popular
oh the greek god of walks well this is
something that's been a part of my life
since i was in uh
wow double a baseball around 2003 i got
dubbed this by the book
moneyball and uh it's funny because i'm
not greek
but uh i'm of romanian descent of my
father's side with the eucharist name so
it was a name change but the greek
community still loves me to this day so
uh and i love i love the greek culture
and a lot of the food so
it's i still consider myself greek in
some ways yeah it was one of those times
where it's wild uh
i got a lot of recognition in the minor
leagues i never had recognition ever in
my life
um you know a little bit here and there
but i was kind of an underdog
so do you think that life would have
been different if you were there
while big data before big data became a
real big thing
it's funny like so when analytics
started coming about
in the early years uh a lot of it was
just back behind the scenes
as baseball players we just went out
there every day we practiced we worked
hard
so analytics became a big deal uh
probably yeah right around the time when
i got drafted
um it started to become more of the norm
of learning about on base percentage
understanding that the the key to you
know baseball is getting on base uh
whether you know on base percentage is
also a part of getting hits
so you know average was a big deal for a
long time but the on base percentage
included walks hit by pitches and it
became a focal point
the data and analytics is really good
for the coaching there's a lot of good
information that is quick and easy
whereas before you have to have
different video angles of the hitters
trying to assess and see what kind of
body movements they have now we have the
ability to assess those body movements
so
when a player is in a funk or doing
something maybe there's something little
that we can take out of it
[Music]
so kevin on that point i'm curious when
you watch the video
and you assess the data how frequent is
it that the data actually is accurate
with what you're seeing in the video
we talk about this all the time is uh
players make
the analytics and then the analytics are
evaluated by other people
that are very smart and intelligent and
understand how to break it down
so that that's one of the funny parts
about it and you know the video the
video doesn't lie
a lot of times i'm sure some some
players must be more connected with the
data than others they have like a date
ahead
yes there are some players that are very
very into the data
uh there's other players that don't want
any data there's a lot of analytics and
like driven into the pitching side
because you're really on offense
you're in control of throwing the ball
it's like golf the ball's sitting right
there
and that's why it's become super big
analytic driven because
you control what you're doing as a
hitter
you're actually on defense you're
reacting to what
they're doing
right one now you were a rookie on the
boston red sox when y'all
vanquished the curse of the bambino do
you really think data had anything to do
with that
our office used data to to get the team
right so
you plug and play players i mean theo
epstein has done a great job of that
over the years is
building a lineup and trying to figure
out what kind of players you want
and i think he did that in a lot of ways
he saw value in certain players
and yeah so like we got a david ortiz
for the minnesota twins that
you know it was a major league player
but
they just didn't see him because they
had other players that they thought were
more valuable
wow so the data helped get the players
on the team but once the players were on
the team that's where the full human
kicked in and
let's feel let's practice let's get
better day by day no data a part of that
once you get to a certain level pretty
much everyone's on a playing field
some are greater athletes than others
physically but
it's the mind and how you slow down and
there's not a lot of analytics for that
a good coach understands the player
and how they can handle certain
analytics and if you
if you understand the player first then
you can introduce the thing
slowly into um the player's mind in
order to make them better every day
thank you so much for your time today
kevin thank you yeah we're excited go
socks
got zach you kevin you
[Music]
so now let's talk about the kaggle
challenge with major league baseball
it's the mlb player digital engagement
forecasting competition
the competition will dive deeper into
the player fandom of america's past time
don't forget there are 50 000 in prizes
and of course
serious bragging rights up for grabs
[Music]
hope you're feeling inspired at home
remember you can try vertex ai for
free in the google cloud console and
visit the companion assets to build what
you've seen here today
that's all for today thanks everyone bye
dale bye mj
stuff peace from nyc
you